wie sieht sie aus die bibliothek in
zukunft werden wir in 100 jahren noch
bücher ausleihen stundenlange
zeitschrift nachdem einen artikel suchen
werden wir überhaupt noch mit papier in
berührung kommen
seit 2009 digitalisiert die
nationalbibliothek großteil ihres
bestandes
damit wissen einer größeren
öffentlichkeit zugänglich wird
florian steffen leiter des
ambitionierten projekts betont die
vorteile für bibliotheksnutzer und wenn
das original das wirklich sicher
versicherte blatter
und wenn du das das ist ehrlicher
ähnlich und wenn die plattform ist und
der tier im vortex straßen
da gibt für sie relevant und tatsächlich
waren ältere zeitschriften bislang nur
auf mikrofilmen einsehbar
mittlerweile ist die st galler zeitung
von 1831 weltweit online zugänglich bis
heute wurden in bern circa 95 millionen
zeitungs und buchseiten eingescannt das
sind erst ganze 48 promille des
bestandes wichtig ist dass die
schriftstücke urheberrechts frei sind
die digitalisierung ist kein mittel um
originale besser zu konservieren
langfristig ist papier immer noch anhalt
basten einen vorteil gibt es dennoch für
die originale digitalisiert auge melden
positiven effekt für bestands vorstellen
dass eine bank mit max bahr muss
schaffen der band
und wenn man das rad der nutzer wirklich
stelle aus digitale kopie der idiot
möglichkeit hier mit stichwort
durchsuchen oder breitere und noch heute
genau ganz allgemein magazin haben
prioritär eingescannt werden
themenschwerpunkte wie schweizer
literatur kunst und architektur eine
weitere methode der digitalisierung ist
das fotografieren
simon schmid digitalisiert derzeit die
sammlung kugelmann rund 2000 werke der
so genannten schweizer kleinmeister
helvetische landschaften in zeichnungen
aquarellen oder öl
eine der wertvollsten sammlungen in der
nationalbibliothek
es liegt der duft die schlankheit
relativ holt sich schäuble zur nachricht
die sache erledigt
gedankenschnell hauses kennen objekt
schon rund von format natürliche
qualität
großen wert legt schmidt auf eine
sorgfältige kontrolle thematisierte die
sachlich damit fahrer richtig sie im
blut und neu traurig vom licht
das machen wir ne kontrollieren und
prozent scharf
so perfekt das bild so viele offene
fragen gibt es noch niemand weiß genau
wie lang digitale daten haltbar sind
welches format man in 100 jahren nutzen
wird auch deshalb werden alle papier
originale behalten
woods formaten im last bayerische
heutige digitale sie stehen sagt jetzt
auch und das ist natürlich stellt dafür
seine stimme fehlt eigentlich nur noch
in mit original versicherte zeichens
stoffe erkennen
die digitalisierung ist also eine
ergänzung ein zusatznutzen
sie soll das analoge produkt nicht
ersetzen